this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
farms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's going to be taking a
look at the bizarre guerrilla warfare
weaponry found in far cry 6. this is one
of the worst ideas i i think i've ever
seen it's some sort of rocket weapon and
they've been mounted in some sort of
backpack frame and it looks like it's a
lot of fun if you want to see more of
jonathan's take on the far cry franchise
you can check out our episode on far cry
2 and if there are any other games guns
and mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan breakdown let us know in the
comment section below if you enjoyed
this series please make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right
over to jonathan
i somehow think of the fn fal or the
foul if you prefer that as quite a far
cry weapon which is weird because i've
never played far cry 2 and apparently
that was the last time we saw it for me
it does feel like a an insurgency type
scenario kind of a rifle still around
all over the world it's a 1950s design
as i'm sure a lot of you know this is
actually
approximately the configuration that's
shown in the game
albeit this one has a top cover mount
optical sight on it and what i'm
actually holding here is the german g1
which is the abortive attempt by the
germans to adopt the belgian
762 fal as to how it's depicted in the
game kind of as you'd expect all i'll
say is that the the recoil seems to be
too low famously the this and the g3 are
really quite brutal to control and is
only really useful for very close
quarters you'd be using this in
semi-automatic but always nice to see um
the fal it's a bit of a classic
oh my
good god pausing
good grief the aptly named humidora
because it really does look like a cigar
box
that is horrific
it's the only word i can use for it it's
creative i'll give them that i can't
really endorse it
i've just noticed in the description for
this thing that it includes a rate of
fire 150 rounds per minute however way
you cut it seems really quite high i
assume that's based on some of these
cowboy action shooter guys who can
absolutely hammer a lever like you
wouldn't believe but as this thing
doesn't have a buttstock you lack the
support to really kind of cane that
lever
they generally
modify the levers on those things at
least to cushion your knuckles from the
from the hard steel of the lever with
some sort of wrap okay so i'm seeing a
lot of guys catch fire here and it seems
that the uh cigar themed shotgun sets
things on fire there's a thematic
um relevance there although it's still a
little perplexing but um you know we
have got incendiary shotgun rounds in in
that exist the famously dragon's breath
that almost acts like a sort of
flamethrower out of the muzzle they
really have gone quite fantasy with this
installment but i don't think that's a
new thing with the far cry fan franchise
this one is really interesting and i
will be honest here and admit that i did
not know about this rifle in fact if i
hadn't cheated and looked it up i would
have said
that's a fictionalized version of an
accuracy international rifle it's not it
is absolutely correct we haven't
obviously got one because i don't know
what it is or didn't know what it is
now i do so this is um in the real world
called the alejandro developed by i
think the cuban state design and
manufacturing capability in 792 by 57
mauser which is a very interesting
choice otherwise it looks like the
photos that i can find
of this thing which looks very much like
a 1980s 90s vintage ai rifle
with a weird sort of extra loop in the
trigger guard which i think is just a
stylistic flourish can't speak to its
capabilities the barrel looks a little
slender for a modern precision rifle but
it looks like the far cry guys have done
a good job modeling it presumably based
on the same few images that i've been
able to find the scope in the game
absolutely bizarre the reticle looks
like
almost like an emoji or something
wouldn't be very useful for precise
aiming and the bizarre kind of towing
shackle on the top of the scope no idea
what that's supposed to be i mean i know
firearms are able to do more these days
with accessories and stuff but i don't
think towing small vehicles is among
those abilities
the stetchkin machine pistol quite a
good job i think and then
we've then got a
heavily decorated version gold plate
i've got to say the decor decorative
firearms in this are well done you know
you could make a real gun look like that
whether you would and why you would want
to are separate questions looks good the
stock which is a real thing it's got a
holster stock like the old c96 mauser
here's to be depicted as wood which is a
mistake i don't think there's a wooden
version easy mistake to make though
because it really does look like wood
but what it actually is is that what's
commonly termed
not strictly bakelite but it is a
related
phenolic resin polymer it does look
rather a lot like
wood it has a sort of grain to it always
see
reminds me of a sort of
makarov on steroids that's also got an
automatic function but it is there is
really not that much in common between
the two
just sort of general
um soviet family resemblance helped i
think by the the shape and style and
color of
the grips but it's a very cool um now
historic firearms
wow this thing is truly special
i almost don't know what to say about
this so we've got a
as it says an improvised compact disc
launcher trying to think about this
seriously if we can there's obviously
very little mass in a cd it's plastic
it's lightweight easily broken this
thing would have to project it at kind
of hypersonic speeds i think velocities
for it to do what we see there in theory
if you shoot a cd
hard enough you can cut someone's head
off with it i never thought i'd say
those words but i just have it isn't
just weaponized this thing still plays
music which
which i have to say is a nice touch so
the last thing you hear before you die
would be
macarena i mean that's that feels like a
fate worse than death to me
we've got um the russian
groza here a little sort of bullpup aks
74u equivalent effectively not
remarkable to see that in a video game
we've covered it before the thing i've
wanted to sort of talk about is that
rather splendid
homemade
red dot sight which appears to be a
can of
sardines
anchovies maybe
they've put a bit of glass on it and for
the red dot there is like a laser
pointer complete with cute little laser
radiation warning i don't know what
class laser this is
shining onto the glass to create your
site and i think for an improvised site
you'd be better off just duct taping the
laser to the weapon and trying to zero
that to it and using that as your
site just literally a laser sight rather
than trying to turn it into a red dot
but i admire the creativity and the
concept and it's clearly a
overarching theme of
semi-improvised firearms which is
interesting in itself
okay being careful not to take out my uh
computer with this monster now this one
has had quite a bit of it
cut away i don't know if you can see on
camera but
this is a rare
hk21e
that has been cut away for instructional
purposes that's what this is this is the
hk21e
and it is this belt fed machine gun
version of the g3 is what this is i've
done a decent job with it with the
animation of this it's just occurred to
me that a lot of lmgs or well any mg
that you're sort of ramboing hip hip
firing
may not always show you the
disintegrating links that hold the belt
of ammunition together so
what's holding these together as the
round is either pushed through or pulled
out
fall away and that's what we see
tumbling out of the side of this gun
here in quite an authentic fashion and
it's just occurred to me that some games
at least
will have overlooked the fact that we
should be seeing links coming out of the
gun maybe it's just that the graphics
here are current generation and it's
drawn my eye to it
right we've got an m14 specifically the
socom 16 version an interesting choice
in itself perhaps more interesting
is the muzzle attachment clear it says
it is a uh
a resolver suppressor so a sort of
fabricated sound suppressor it looks
like the back part is an oil filter but
then what looks like clip to that
is
like a like a windshield wiper
filler bottle thing this would work
depending on your definition of the word
work
so oil filters will
remove some decibels from the report of
a shot bearing in mind this is a full
power rifle so it's
very loud to begin with the plastic
component is going to act as an
expansion chamber to some degree
it has a very large aperture at the end
though so it's not going to be super
effective if it is effective and you get
a build up of pressure within that
container the container is likely to
split you know there's a reason why
sound suppressors are not made out of
soft plastic it's liable to split after
one or two shots
right so this thing in actual use is
really quite interesting heating is
definitely a problem for suppressors
they are con because they're containing
propellant gases that have that have not
long come out of the very hot chamber
and the increasingly hot barrel
depending on how many shots you're
firing they will retain heat but this is
highly gamified so it getting hotter and
becoming inefficient to the point of the
gunshots no longer being suppressed i
don't think that could happen also this
is heating up so much that it catches
fire and the barrel can can glow red hot
white hot and actually bend and a bullet
can even come out of the side of the
barrel if it gets hot enough so that
level of heat absolutely
what it can't do is put itself out
there's not a little miniature team of
firemen uh firefighters running down the
barrel and putting out the the flame so
you'd have to you'd have to quench this
in some water or something or just crack
on and hope that the heat didn't become
catastrophic for the whole weapon but
it's a very interesting twist kind of
kind of the next level of video game
improvised suppresses it's quite
interesting to see
okay one of my
favorite firearms of all time
the ar-15 this is the m16a1 which is i
think by a lot of popular consensus at
this point
the best
of the lot this is possibly the best
in-game model of one that i've seen so
far there's some really nice texture
texturing on the handguards depending on
when the actual the rifle was made and
what sort of service life it's had you
get all sorts of interesting texture
changes on these smooth slightly flimsy
plastic handguards
and um we've got it there it looks like
they have been they're actually
over painted interesting to see it's not
just the improvised sound suppressors
that are kind of heating up and catching
fire the commercial ones like this are
as well but they're heating up really
quickly so after not many shots they're
glowing bright red it would take a lot
more than that for it for this thing to
glow just because that's an indicator
that the whole rifle is overheating
quite an intriguing way to try and
balance out the advantages of the sound
suppressor makes you make careful use of
it
[Music]
this is one of the weirder things in the
game not because it isn't
a real gun it is so what we see here is
a slightly weird
thing in its own right a revolving
sporting shotgun that's then been turned
sort of back into a revolver pistol by
simply chopping it down like you would
saw off a shotgun normally now if this
thing was around in
fictional cuba then
you may well want to do that to make
better use of it but you'd still be
better off with a real revolver just
being a shotgun doesn't make something
super powerful so i suppose the the
advantage here over a conventional
revolver would be that so limited shots
but large capacity uh so a handgun
firing buckshot if you can
manage the thing in theory would be
worth having in
this kind of
improbable scenario that we find
ourselves playing in not so much in any
real world scenario so a real thing that
has been heavily rule of cooled
oh okay insta pause
and for some reason i haven't even taken
in what the gun is yet but i've seen the
belt of cartridges feeding into it
and they all have dimpled primers we see
this in movies all the time because
inert rounds are usually or are often
made
from fired
cases it's interesting because games of
course don't have to worry about
economics of making inert rounds you
don't have to worry about safety at all
so that's just a mistake they have
modeled a fired round okay the gun
itself is the rpd as some of you might
have spotted
if you didn't don't feel bad because
it's missing its
probably probably its most obvious
recognition feature which is that um
distinctive clamshell wooden handguard
that's not there instead we've got some
sort of a vertical foregrip a pistol
grip i can't quite make out what it is
almost looked ar15 shaped that's been
clamped in place around the barrel i
don't i haven't seen an rpd missing its
handguard and with a vertical full grip
so i'm guessing that's meant to be some
sort of an improvised modification in
keeping with the delightful colour
scheme and the various other bells and
whistles that we see attached to weapons
in this game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the svd makes yet another comeback i am
not at all surprised to see it in the
game an interesting point on these in
the wild as it were when they're
recovered from
conflict zones
where they are in use they're in use
with an optical sight but if you didn't
have access to the optical sight
what would you do well i don't think it
would be this i think you would just
rely on the iron sights it's a lot more
about the skill of the user and the
inherent accuracy of the of the weapon
you can't just slap a scope on something
and magically become more accurate as we
see in pop culture and you what you
definitely don't want to do
is lash up
literally a telescopic site from some
vaguely cylindrical found objects and
lenses of some sort
and then draw on the reticle
with a sharpie that is not going to lend
itself
to any kind of precision even if you can
get this thing to reliably shoot to
point of aim at a given distance it is
not going to retain that ability for
more than one shot
i don't know if i'm allowed to use the
word batshit on this channel but um they
can bleep it uh if not this is one of
the worst ideas i i think i've ever seen
i mean practically speaking there's no
reason why you couldn't do it you would
end up with a char broiled backside what
this should have if you i mean i can't
believe i'm even suggesting this please
don't try and recreate this at home is
some sort of a
shield coming down off the back of it i
mean you get away with that with um jet
packs just to an extent where due to the
way you're holding yourself you don't
get scorched necessarily but it looks to
me
like your backside or
your right foot the way he's crashing
down would suffer some some
heat
at least um discomfort shall we say so
what is this thing well you tell me it's
some sort of rocket weapon i'm guessing
they're meant to be like laws rockets or
something but they don't look like a
lure rocket and they've been mounted in
some sort of backpack frame triggered
with some sort of electrical ignition
i've now realized that this thing has
some sort of homing capability so these
are not just uh dumb rockets how are i
mean i suppose passive infrared if the
missiles have some sort of passive
infrared seeker you need some sort of a
cue be that an audio tone or a red light
something to show that this thing is
ready to launch and is
locked on not getting any of that with
the backpack launcher it's just
magically guiding itself onto the target
quite effectively by the look of it but
i can absolutely see why they put in
this in the game because it really does
change things up and it looks like it's
a lot of fun
[Music]
okay quite an exciting one this the bp2
actually the
vhs2 for a moment i wondered if bp was
some sort of play on betamax as the uh
age-old rival to vhs i'm aging myself
with this comment i realized here is a
real croatian
hs product bhs
ii and
it looks pretty good
got all of the right features this thing
has is unusual for a bullpup firearm in
that it has an adjustable buttstock
normally with it with a bullpup because
you don't have a conventional stock on
it you can't adjust for things like body
armor different body shapes
they obviously wanted to build that in
how successful it will be remains
unclear but this has already become
quite significant in the movie world and
it's now bleeding through into games as
well
so our version is the is the k2 so it
has the carbine length
barrel whereas the version of the game
is the full length rifle barrel but
everything else about it is the same
okay so watching this thing in action
the
rail on the top is different to what's
fitted to our rifle now i don't know
this system well enough yet to know
whether what's shown in the game is a
correct rail or if they've got it wrong
but ours has
backup sites built in
to the rail which means the view at the
back of the gun
is quite different
to what we see here
normally of course you'd want some sort
of a sight on there in this case it has
backup sights clamped to the rail itself
instead that's possible that's an option
they have got the the reload correct
which is cool so
if we [ __ ] this with a magazine on
simulate it being empty
and then
replace the magazine and what he's doing
there is reaching to the rear and
pressing this catch
to allow the bolt to go home so they've
done the homework on this so yeah i
think one of the more accurate
guns in the game in terms of depiction
thanks very much for watching guys we
always appreciate it that was the guns
of far cry 6. have a look in the
description for links over to the royal
armouries we've got
social media stuff going on got our own
youtube channel and of course we'll be
back on gamespot again next week thanks
a lot
[Music]
[Music]
you